und damit kommen wir zum nächsten
tagesordnungspunkt da geht es wieder
einmal kann man sagen um energie die
energie und energiesicherheit spielte in
dieser sitzungswoche ja schon das ein
oder andere mal eine rolle denn
natürlich ist durch den angriff
russlands auf die ukraine klar die lage
ist angespannt und so möchten die
fraktionen von spd bündnis 90/die grünen
und fdp
das energie sicherungs gesetz ändern das
wird hier angezeigt mit energie
sicherungs gesetz
1975 denn in dieser zeit wurde es in den
70er jahren
formuliert damals noch als reaktion auf
die ölkrise seitdem wurde es kaum
geändert und angesichts der aktuellen
lage möchte nun aber möchten die
fraktionen nun die staatlichen kontroll
möglichkeiten noch einmal stärken das
bedeutet dass
die bundesregierung und auch die
verwaltung des staates unternehmen
stärker kontrollieren kann oliver
krischer der zuständige parlamentarische
staatssekretär jan reuters
anfang der woche konnten wir berichten
dass unser bemühen uns schritt für
schritt von ris russischen energie
importen unabhängig zu machen dass wir
dabei ein gutes stück vorangekommen sind
kohle importe aus russland sind schon
deutlich reduziert der anteil von erdöl
war mal bei 35% wir sind jetzt auf dem
weg zu zwölf und der abschied von
russischem gas das waren 55 da sind wir
aktuell bei 35 das ist noch eine längere
herausforderung aber daran arbeiten wir
wir haben viele maßnahmen ergriffen
effizienzmaßnahmen sowie verbrauch zu
reduzieren wir bauen die erneuerbaren
aus wir schaffen aber auch neue
infrastruktur um unseren bezug zu
diversifizieren und wenn es gut geht
können wir schon nächste woche
vielleicht in wilhelmshaven mit dem
ersten schwimmenden mit dem bau des
ersten schwimmenden lng terminals
beginnen das sind fortschritte um sehr
konkret und sehr schnell von russischen
energielieferungen unabhängig zu werden
es zeigt aber auch es zeigt aber auch
wir sind noch nicht so weit und die
unsicherheit an den energiemärkten ist
riesengroß die preise sind hoch es sind
risiken vorhanden und niemand niemand
von uns kann heute sagen wann und gegen
wen putin energieimporte als waffen
einsetzten wird wir haben das in dieser
woche im fall von polen und bulgarien
erlebt dass putin bereit ist das zu tun
aber wir werden uns nicht einschüchtern
lassen sondern unsere politik ist darauf
ausgerichtet dass wir uns für den fall
wappnen dass sich die situation zuspitzt
das zeichnet unsere politik aus meine
damen und herren
und all das ist nichts was wir uns
wünschen können wenn wir reale
versorgungsengpässe haben die haben wir
gott sei dank im moment noch nicht dann
wird das gesamtgesellschaftlich zu
enormen einschnitten führen dann reden
wir über abschaltungen von
industriezweigen dann reden wir für
folgen von nicht produktion dann reden
wir von arbeitslosigkeit da reden wir
von menschen die kein einkommen haben
die nicht zur arbeit gehen können dann
reden wir über gestörte lieferketten
dann reden wir über gestörte
versorgungsstruktur aber je besser wir
vorbereitet sind je schneller und
umfassender behandelt je besser können
wir auch mit der krise umgehen und
deshalb
novellieren wir jetzt das energie
sicherungs gesetz aus den 1970 er jahren
aus dem zeiten der ölkrise und das ist
einfach notwendig dass wir dieses gesetz
ins 21 jahrhundert bringen denn die
regeln niedergeschrieben sind die
stammen aus einer zeit da gab es noch
kein internet aber noch die sowjetunion
und ich glaube das allein macht deutlich
dass hier gehandelt werden muss wir
müssen dieses gesetz in der aktuellen
krise auf die höhe der zeit bringen
[Applaus]
um die wichtigsten die wichtigsten
punkte sind dabei es klingt banal aber
wir brauchen eine digitale plattform für
den bereich gas das thema gas wird in
diesem gesetz nur nicht in den
notwendigen art und weise adressiert das
ist auf erdöl zugeschnitten wir brauchen
aber jetzt eine digitale plattform wo
verbraucht und einspeisung gesteuert
werden können wo wir eingreifen können
dann wenn eine gasmenge lage eintritt um
das entsprechend managen zu können das
ist ein ganz ganz entscheidender punkt
hierfür eine rechtsgrundlage zu schaffen
wir brauchen weiterhin eine
treuhandverwaltung für unternehmen die
kritische infrastrukturen in nicht in
der weise betreiben die sie betrieben
werden müssen dass diese gefahr real ist
haben wir schon erlebt seit dem ausbruch
des krieges und deshalb ist es absolut
wichtig dass wir hier in dem gesetz
hierfür die voraus vor de rung schaffen
und ich sage auch ganz klar als ultima
ratio unter klar benannten und sehr
engen bedingungen muss auch die
enteignung möglich sein denn es kann
nicht sein dass jemand der eine
kritische infrastruktur für die
energieversorgung kritische
infrastruktur besitzt und betreibt und
diese falsch betreibt unsere
energieversorgung gefährdet auch das
regeln wir in dem gesetz wir brauchen
auch eine regelung
eine regelung zur preisanpassung meine
damen und herren denn wenn preise
kurzfristig steigern müssen lieferanten
unternehmen die weitergeben können denn
wenn sie das nicht können dann droht der
zusammenbruch von unternehmen von
energieversorgungsunternehmen unter
umständen ganze kettenreaktion und wenn
diese unternehmen dann nicht mehr da
sind dann können sie auch nicht ihrem
versorgungsauftrag nachgehen auch dafür
brauchen wir klare regeln und wir
brauchen bessere regeln für die
solidarität in der europäischen union
wir arbeiten schon sehr intensiv und
sehr eng mit unseren nachbarn zusammen
aber wir wollen uns natürlich im fall
der gasmenge lage unterstützen wir
brauchen regeln dafür wie wir gemeinsam
das das schaffen können und das leistet
dieses gesetz meine damen und herren
normalerweise ist es so dass man sich
bei dem einbringen und dem beschluss
eines gesetzes wünscht dass es möglichst
oft angewendet wird ich sage dass hier
sehr deutlich wir wünschen uns dass
dieses gesetz am besten gar nicht
angewendet wird denn nicht wir wissen
wir wissen
das sind starke eingriffe des staates in
den markt beim thema preise treuhand
enteignung aber wir müssen für den
handlungsverlauf fall handlungsfähig
sein und die gewährleistung der
energiesicherheit
ist eine staatliche aufgabe meine damen
und herren deshalb sollte dieses gesetz
so bald wie möglich in kraft treten und
ich bitt und appelliere an sie ist zügig
und konstruktiv bereit zu beraten ich
bedanke mich jetzt schon mal für ihre
unterstützung bei diesem weg den wir den
wir gehen zeigen wir wie leistungsfähig
effizient und staat unsere demokratie in
dieser frage ist auch das ist unsere
antwort an putin dankeschön
oliver krischer der parlamentarische
staatssekretär
dieser gesetzentwurf wurde hier von den
fraktionen eingebracht aber es gibt
sogenannte
formulierungshilfen vom kabinett von
daher spricht dann auch der
staatssekretär andreas jung jetzt für
die unionsfraktion eine
konstruktive beratung dieses gesetzes
angeraten ich will für unsere fraktion
sagen dafür sind wir nicht nur bereits
das ausdrücklich unsere position wir
müssen in dieser krise auch als antwort
auf putin
das gilt für einen ehrgeizigen zeitplan
der vorgesehen ist ja für eine
verabschiedung in der nächsten woche und
eine anhörung auf die wir wert gelegt
haben am montag in der nächsten
sitzungswoche steht dieser zügigen
beratung nicht entgegen können aber die
qualität der beratung verbessern und
damit zeigen wir dass wir nicht nur
handlungsfähig sind sondern wir sind
auch handlungswillig als parlament und
diese dieser handlungswillig kommt auch
dadurch zum ausdruck dass wir einerseits
auch für unsere fraktion klarmachen die
regierung muss in dieser situation auch
kurzfristig handlungsmacht haben
einerseits und andererseits müssen die
wesentlichen entscheidungen vom
parlament getroffen werden in diesem
geiste werden wird die beratungen führen
auch wenn es eine fraktion sein bringt
ist darf ich jetzt schon prognostizieren
wird trotzdem das struck gesetz gelten
zweitens
staatssekretär krischer hat angesprochen
die regelungen die hier vorgeschlagen
werden zur stärkung der europäischen
solidarität zu der bekennen wir uns
ausdrücklich und gerade in dieser woche
in der putin den gashahn für polen und
bulgarien
abgestellt hat den worten der
solidarität müssen taten der
zusammenarbeit folgen die regelungen in
diesem gesetz sind ein ausdruck davon
wir brauchen zusammenarbeit wir brauchen
zusammenhalt wir brauchen gemeinsamkeit
wir dürfen uns nicht erpressen lassen
wir dürfen uns nicht
auseinanderdividieren lassen in der
europäischen gemeinschaft es ist eine
klare botschaft und der eindrückliche
botschaft aus der europäischen
wertegemeinschaft
und ja auch wir sind der überzeugung
dass es zusätzliche
eingriffsmöglichkeiten braucht und wir
wissen dass das was hier vorgeschlagen
ist nämlich die möglichkeit
treuhänder einzusetzen und als ultima
ratio auch enteignungen anzuordnen dass
es schwere eingriffe sind aber auch
solche schweren eingriffen können
kurzfristig notwendig seien
gleichzeitig legen wir aber wert darauf
dass angesichts der schwere dieser
eingriffe umso mehr die wesentlichen
entscheidungen von diesem parlament
getroffen werden und hier sehen wir noch
diskussionsbedarf was das
ausformulierung des konkretisierung der
regelung angeht hier ist vorgeschlagen
eine rechtsverordnung ohne zustimmung
des bundestages da muss ich sagen dass
überzeugt uns noch nicht da muss das
parlament mehr mitsprache haben mehr
konkretisierung im gesetz und ich halte
auch den vorschlag dass welt es zu einer
enteignung kommt dass der kurzfristig
gehandelt werden muss gegebenenfalls in
dieser situation dass deshalb eine einen
exekutiven vorsprung gibt die regierung
muss kurzfristig hunting das ist klar
aber dass im nachhinein eine solche
entscheidung da auch der kontrolle des
parlaments unterliegen sollte das halten
wir für einen vorschlag dem wir
nachgehen sollten dem wir nachgehen
wollen wir müssen also das maß finden
zwischen der möglichkeit der exekutive
zu handeln und parlamentarischer
entscheidungen rückkopplung und genau
das wird der maßstab sein mit dem wir in
diesen beratungen die debatte führen
werden die dinge bewerten insbesondere
wollen wir dabei auch diskutieren über
die frage des mechanismus der
vorgeschlagene
preisanpassung ja wir müssen wenn es zu
einem fifa.com stopp kommt
kaskaden verhindern wir müssen
verhindern dass es zu kettenreaktionen
kommt die zu wirtschaftlichen
gesellschaftlichen schäden führen da
wollen wir aber noch mal genauer
anschauen ob das was vorgeschlagen ist
wirklich die ausgewogenheit aller
beteiligten der energieversorger aber
auch der verbraucher in angemessener
weise wirklich schon berücksichtigt das
muss diskutiert das muss geprüft werden
insgesamt halte es für notwendig dass
jetzt vorsorge getroffen wird für eine
weitere zuspitzung
da ist dieses gesetz ein ausdruck davon
wir drängen darauf dass insgesamt ein
plan ein gesamtkonzept vorgelegt wird
wie können wir ohne russische energie
gut über den nächsten winter kommen mit
dem was an diese beschrieben haben die
gemacht wurden mit weiteren maßnahmen
die geplant sind wir drängen auch darauf
dass ein gesamtkonzept vorgelegt wird
welche einsparung sind wohl möglich und
vertretbar welche optionen gibt es um im
strombereich
gaskraftwerke zu kompensieren haben das
gesamtkonzept es kommt zum ende wir
werden uns konstruktiv in die beratungen
einbringen herzlichen dank
andreas jung war das hat hier einige
punkte angesprochen die er noch
diskutieren möchte und natürlich auch
das stroh gesetzt es eben kein gesetz so
den bundestag verlässt wie es
hineingekommen ist mina spricht jetzt
für die spd-fraktion
die frage das gesamtkonzept das ist
natürlich ein hehres ziel wir müssen sie
aber auch anerkennen dass wir in einer
situation stecken in der akku des
handelns auf jeweils immer wieder sich
neu
herausbildende herausforderungen
angesagt ist und gesamtkonzepte haben
nun mal
dann die eigenschaft dass sie etwas
längeren planungszeiten voraussetzen und
die hat man in solchen momenten nicht
insofern sind wir darauf angewiesen die
handlungsfähigkeit durch akute
nachjustierungen sicherzustellen und
darüber hinaus natürlich auch
zielvorgaben zu haben aber die liegen
etwa mit dem oster paket und dem sommer
paket im umstieg auf erneuerbare
energien oder ab wann wird parallel
unter hochdruck gearbeitet
[Applaus]
der staat hat eine garantenstellung als
ausdruck von daseinsvorsorge bei
unverzichtbaren versorgungsleistungen
dies ist in unserem grundgesetz und den
gesetzlichen regelwerke verankert auch
außerhalb von krisenzeiten um in einer
freiheitlichen gesellschaft dem anspruch
von freiheit gerechtigkeit und
solidarität in einer sozial ökologischen
marktwirtschaft gerecht zu werden
richtigerweise gibt es keine
abschließende meinung darüber was zu
leistungen der daseinsvorsorge zelt es
ist aber dem wesen von darf 1 vorsorge
immer nennt das energieversorgung immer
dazu zählt
[Applaus]
als brecht erst recht in
krisensituationen ist vorsorge zu
treffen hierfür gilt es die instrumente
der krisenbewältigung zu stärken im
krisenfall zählt dabei auch die
schnelleren führungsfähigkeit des
staates dem diente bereits die
verabschiedung des gasspeicher gesetzes
mit zeitlichen vorstands vorgaben dass
er vor wenigen wochen hier verabschiedet
haben und nun ist das energie
sicherungsnetz eingesetzt einzudringen
aus dem jahre 1975
als staatssekretär oliver krischer hat
es schon erwähnt aus welchen zeiten das
ist jenseits der gesetzlichen
rahmenbedingungen sind wir politisch
betrachtet alle berufen bei unserem
bestreben nach unabhängigkeit von
rohstoffimporten aus russland die
grenzen der leistungsfähigkeit zu
beachten auch diese zählt so energie
sicher
gerade in bezug auf die lieferketten und
regionale unterschiede ist dies mitunter
eine existenzielle herausforderung das
sehen wir gerade in diesen zeiten
einerseits müssen wir allein schon und
die uns nicht erpressbar zu machen und
vermeidbare geldflüsse nach russland
einzustellen so schnell es geht
unabhängig von importen aus russland
werden
andererseits darf uns aber eben diese
zielvorgabe ihrerseits nicht überfordern
insofern ist nach meiner überzeugung in
der frage nach weiteren im bus aktuell
äußerste zurückhaltung geboten
die nachhaltigste unabhängigkeit von
energieimporten ich habe es eingangs
erwähnt auch zur einstellung von
geldflüssen nach russland ist über den
schnellstmöglichen ausbau erneuerbarer
energien zu erreichen dafür müssen wir
unsere handlungsfähigkeit aber auch
erhalten der heute einzubringen der
gesetzentwurf enthält maßgaben der
präzisierung bestehende un aufnahme
weiterer verordnungsermächtigungen
erhält regelungen zur einführung einer
digitalen plattform und anpassung von
gas versicherungs verordnung das amt als
sicherungs verantwortung um die
lastverteilung effektiv vollziehen zu
können die auch bei solidaritäts
maßnahmen nach der europäischen sos
verordnung erforderlich werden kann dies
dient einem schnellen und praktikablen
verzug von solidaritäts ersuchen die an
deutschland gerichtet werden können
mitgliedstaaten können auch die
unterstützung deutschlands und auch
untereinander zählen wenn es zu
engpässen kommen
[Applaus]
um die versorgungssicherheit zu
gewährleisten müssen wir auch an die
treuhandverwaltung denken auch dass es
enthalten und es ist schon erwähnt
worden auch als ultima ratio die
enthaltung vorsehen das gehört leider
auch mit dazu jahren und es muss auch
über die möglichkeit von
preisanpassungen bei verminderten
gasimporten nachgedacht werden können
auch das ist enthalten mit diesen
weiteren maßnahmen für einen so die
damen recht kommen habe ich kommt zur
versorgungssicherheit gehen wir mit der
heutigen einbringung nun in die
parlamentarischen beratungen zur novelle
des energie sicherungs gesetzes und
weiteren vorschriften ich danke für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
der nächste redner in der debatte ist
rainer kraft ersetzt für die afg
fraktion im ausschuss für klimaschutz
und energie
[Applaus]
[Musik]
geschätzte präsidentin werte kollegen
der vorliegende gesetzesentwurf ist
nichts anderes als ihr eingeständnis
dass die energiepolitik der kanzler
schröder und merkel gescheitert ist in
diesen verschenkten 23 regierungsjahren
von spd union fdp und grünen wurde die
hervorragende energieversorgung
deutschlands mit zuverlässiger und
preiswerte energie von ihnen mutwillig
zerstört sie haben die bürger sie haben
die bürger und unternehmen dieses land
ist damit in eine existenzgefährdende
situation gebracht und deutschland in
große abhängigkeit einer fremden macht
erklären wir lediglich ob es sich nur um
pure dummheit oder um verrat handelt mit
krone und dem krieg der ukraine
versuchen sie sich nun aus ihrer
verantwortung zu stehlen dabei urteilte
das wall street journal bereits im jahr
2019 also vor corona und weit vor der
russischen invasion dass ihre
energiepolitik die dümmste der welt ist
und wen hat uns diese ihre dome
energiepolitik geführt zu unflexible
stromerzeugung des märkten und teuren
endverbraucherpreisen dazu ein schnelles
beispiel von 2010 bis 2012 stieg der
gaspreis in deutschland um circa 40
prozent als folge wurde die verstromung
aus gas um die hälfte reduziert
verbunden mit einer entsprechenden
anstieg der kohleverstromung die strom
erzeugen also vom teureren gas in die
preiswertere kohle aus und vermieden es
so den gas anstieg über die strompreise
an die endverbraucher weiterzugeben
nennt man marktwirtschaft springen
schnell ins jahr 2021 erneut der
gaspreis ist extrem hoch und wo befindet
sich die stromversorger stromproduktion
aus gas auf rekordniveau weil ihr dauer
subventionierten strom der erneuerbaren
in 2021 immer noch nicht liefert aber
einen ausweichenden kohle nicht mehr
möglich ist weil unverantwortliche
agieren der anhänger einer klima wodurch
sekte ein kohle ausstiegs gesetz
verabschiedet haben
als folge davon wird teures gas weiter
verstromt und treibt damit den gaspreis
vor sich her die schuld daran tragen sie
sie haben die diversifizierung in der
stromerzeugung branche beerdigt durch
ihre ausstiegsbeschlüsse sie haben die
marktwirtschaft im energiesektor
abgeschafft sie besser nur nun das
angesprochene gesetz nach dem gas wird
knapp in deutschland aber moment mal so
knapp der krise kann das gas in
deutschland ja gar nicht sein denn diese
regierung unternimmt seinen wochen und
monaten nichts um die gasverstromung in
deutschland zu reduzieren dass man indem
man mehr strom aus der kohle gewinnt
oder indem man mehr strom aus
kernenergie produziert was sagen denn
eigentlich kohlen unwohl jahren dazu
dass sie wertvolles gas weiterhin hier
in deutschland verstromen nur weil sie
sich weigern kohle und kernkraft zur
stromerzeugung zu benutzen
sagen sie daher ja dort abholen und
ganze jahr zur kernkraft in deutschland
ihr gesetzentwurf legt nun da wie und
wann sie besitzer kritischer
infrastruktur und betreuern
verwaltungsstellen und oder enteignen
können die notwendige bedingung dazu
lautet zitat wenn dem sektor energie
dienen der aufgaben nicht erfüllt werden
und eine beeinträchtigung der
versorgungssicherheit droht zitat ende
herzlichen glückwunsch herr
staatssekretär
sie können damit am ersten tag nach
inkrafttreten dieses gesetzes sämtliche
wind und photovoltaik anlagen in
deutschland autoren stellen oder
enteignen denn diese erfüllen ihre zitat
dem sektor energie die den aufgaben
niemals zufrieden stellend und sie
gefährden die versorgungssicherheit in
deutschland permanent
aber alle ihre staatliche planwirtschaft
bringt an dieser stelle nämlich gar
nichts es handelt sich nämlich um einen
systemfehler dieser minderwertigen
energieerzeugungs methoden die fdp hat
immer davor gewarnt
aber nun geht die energiewende sagt auf
das heißt nein nein sie geht noch nicht
auf sie kommt gerade erst einmal für die
bürger bedeutet dies explodierende
kosten und unsichere versorgung während
die energiewende lobbys
los ruft hier gerade rein die
energiewende lobby jetzt nun mit
steuerzahlergeld gemästet wird
wenn erinnert auch ihr gesetzentwurf
nichts ihr versagen lässt sich in drei
worten zusammenfassen energie wenn der
atomausstieg kohleausstieg
michael grusa fdp fraktions der nächste
redner
und michael kruse ist der
energiepolitische sprecher seiner
fraktion
sehr geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen
insbesondere herr kollege kraft also ich
möchte gerne für die koalition
feststellen schrott ist hier nicht der
erneuerbare strom sondern schrott ist
ihre energiepolitische analyse diese
gerade getätigt als
wir nicht nur eine meinung dazu haben
sondern ich will es ihnen auch erklären
dass sie es hier seit dem angriff
russlands auf die ukraine geschafft
haben in jeder ihrer energiepolitischen
reden überhaupt gar nicht zu erwähnen
dass russland in europa einen krieg
begonnen hat das ist so beschämend das
ist so beschämend für dieses hohe haus
das mir persönlich sie eine
zwischenfrage fehle von herrn kraft ja
nachdem jetzt folgenden applaus um einen
kommentar
herr kollege kruse
ich weiß nicht um irgendwas das erwähnen
des völkerrechtswidrigen angriffskrieg
so russlands unbedingt etwas mit ihrer
oder mit der vergangenen die politik zu
tun hat aber um hier meine rede ich
gerade gehalten habe vielleicht war ich
da zu zitieren ich habe
selbstverständlich hier die russische
invasion der ukraine als tatbestand
genannt selbstständig wurde sie erwähnt
dass tatsächlich habe darauf hingewiesen
dass die situation die existiert in
bulgarien und dem polen die dringend auf
gas angewiesen sind dass sie hier lieber
verstromen das hat unsere eigenen
heimischen energieträger wie braunkohle
die am 15 ein spalter abgeschaltet wird
mit zwei gigawatt leistung und die noch
existieren kleinkraftrad einzuschalten
um den gasmarkt zu entlasten also
selbstverständlich so dass hier
angesprochen
zunächst mal haben sie es ja jetzt
genauso wiederholt wie sie es hier dann
maximal überhaupt vortragen nämlich für
sie versuchen das wort krieg
systematisch zu vermeiden und ich habe
einem ihrer kollegen
ich habe einem ihrer kollegen schon
mehrfach dazwischen berufen dass er das
wort doch einfach mal in diesem
zusammenhang erwähnen möge das ist ja
das ist ja keine rede was sie jetzt
machen ja jetzt müssten sie es noch in
den richtigen zusammenhang stellen und
dann noch die richtigen analysen daraus
tätigen dann wären sie eine geeignete
fraktion für dieses haus was ich ihnen
was ich ihnen sagen möchte zu holen
konnten
[Applaus]
was ich ihnen gerne zu polen und
bulgarien sagen möchte ist das folgende
auch dass ihre analyse nicht richtig
denn das sind die beiden länder die es
als allererstes geschafft haben klar zu
erkennen wer hier der aggressor ist und
zwar schon bevor der krieg ausgebrochen
ist und deswegen haben diese länder sehr
kluge entscheidung getroffen sich
unabhängig zu machen polen hat eine
pipeline richtung norwegen gebaut sie
ist in fertigstellung polen hat die
richtigen entscheidungen im bereich der
energie terminals an der küste getroffen
bulgarien hat sich sehr klug
diversifiziert richtung süden pipeline
aus griechenland sie wissen dass fast
fertig das bedeutet die länder die hier
die entscheidungen getroffen haben die
stehen besser da und weil sie diese
analyse nicht haben tätigen können und
weil sie diesen sachverhalt nicht haben
erkennen können sind auch ihre
schlussfolgerung aus ihrer wie ich sagte
schrott analyse falsch herzlichen dank
das war jetzt das ende meiner antwort
ich habe mit großer freude vernommen
dass es hier demokratische fraktion gibt
die zum beispiel gerade nicht in der
regierung sitzen und die trotzdem
verstanden haben was die stunde
geschlagen hat der in dieser krieg hat
für jeden von uns in diesem hause eine
neue realität geschaffen und für viele
menschen in diesem land für viele
menschen in europa und deswegen bedeutet
das für uns alle auch dass wir das set
an maßnahmen dass wir grundsätzlich hier
im raum am liebsten vorschlagen
überprüfen müssen und auf diese neue
realität
schnellstmöglich anpassen müssen ich
freue mich deshalb besonders dass
mindestens eine fraktion hier im hause
schon sehr deutlich erklärt hat diese
beratungen konstruktiv begleiten zu
bringen kann für uns zu sagen dass wir
konstruktiven vorschlägen sehr offen
gegenüber stehen und dass wir
insbesondere uns freuen dass hier auch
im verfahren
zugeständnisse gemacht worden sind das
nicht selbstverständlich aber es zeigt
dass in einer so schweren stunde wie der
in der wir uns jetzt gerade befinden die
menschen klar zu unterscheiden sind in
diesem haus zwischen den fraktionen die
bereit sind verantwortung für dieses
land zu übernehmen und den fraktionen
die nicht bereit sind verantwortung für
dieses land zu übernehmen und die die es
nicht sind die sollten dann für dieses
land bitte auch niemals verantwortung
übernehmen dürfen
wir regeln mit diesem gesetz viele
wichtige maßnahmen wir nehmen erstmals
die gasspeicher in die kritische
infrastruktur auf haben ja schon das gas
speicher gesetz beschlossen vor einigen
wochen und das ist sehr wichtig dass die
gasspeicher jetzt auch in die kritische
infrastruktur hinein kommen es ist zudem
wichtig dass wir endlich auch mit der
digitalisierung schritthalten 1975
konnte man noch nicht sehen was man
heute an daten generieren kann und auch
braucht um kluge entscheidungen zu
treffen wir alle hier zusammen wir sind
für den energiemarkt der schiedsrichter
der schiedsrichter ist der der das spiel
am laufen hält er ist derjenige der
dafür sorgt dass zum beispiel wettbewerb
auch in schwierigen zeiten funktionieren
kann genau diesen wettbewerb schützen
wir mit diesem instrument und deswegen
ist es für uns als freie demokraten
selbstverständlich jeder der kritische
infrastruktur in deutschland gegen die
deutschen und europäischen interessen
missbraucht der kann nicht weiter
eigentümer dieser kritischen
infrastruktur sein meine damen und
herren
dazu gibt es dann ganz zwei ganz
konkrete maßnahme ist eigentlich die
treuhänderschaft und das andere ist die
ultima ratio die enteignung und
glauben sie mir als liberaler volkswirt
war es nicht meine vorstellung im
letzten jahr als wir um diese mandate
hier gestritten haben dass ich hier
vorne stehen würde und ihnen vorschlagen
würde das in deutschland möglicherweise
enteignung notwendig sein würden und die
tatsache dass wir uns diesem instrument
trotzdem nähern zeigt was die neue
realität in diesem land ist und
insbesondere die kollegen auf der
rechten sollten sich dann mal selbst
sehr kritisch überprüfen ob sie
eigentlich schon verstanden haben was
diese neue realität für unser land für
unsere sicherheit ganz genau bedeutet
kunst aber auch eines klar wenn eine
solche ultima ratio angewendet wird dann
ist zwingend erforderlich dass
unternehmen die der ost die
eigentümerschaft wechseln auch wieder in
privater hand kommen unsere fraktion
wird an dieser stelle darauf dringen
dass eine privatisierung and an
entsprechender stelle folgen muss denn
ich glaube das gehört sofern es dazu wir
wollen hier kein neues instrument
schaffen um staatswirtschaft zu
betreiben sondern wir schaffen hier ein
instrument um wettbewerb und dem markt
zu schützen und deswegen freuen wir uns
sehr auf die konstruktiven beratungen
herzlichen dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit
michael kruse war das und hatte selber
angemerkt doch irgendwie ungewöhnlich
die zeiten sind dass die fdp hier auch
für enteignung als letzten schritt
plädiert gesine lötzsch spricht als
nächstes stellvertretender
vorstandsvorsitzender der
zentrale satz dieses gesetzes ist die
möglichkeit einer enteignung wir als
linke sagen kritische infrastruktur
gehört dauerhaft in die öffentliche hand
und das ist glaube ich die richtige und
wichtige forderung in dieser sport
treiben und dann mache ich natürlich
gleich hinunter zur rede des fdp
vertreters sie haben gerade gesagt wenn
denn die krise vorbei sein sollte dann
muss wieder reprieve reprivatisiert
werden das ist der falsche weg denn das
wäre der gleiche weg wie in der
finanzkrise damals wurden mit
steuergeldern die banken gerettet dann
wurde auf kosten der allgemeinheit eine
sicherheit stabilität wieder hergestellt
und die banken wurden wieder
privateigentum so darf das nicht
weitergehen meine damen und herren wir
befinden uns in einer dauerkrise wir
befanden uns schon vor dem krieg
russlands gegen die ukraine in einer
krise und wir müssen doch aus diesen
krisen aus der folge der krise die
schlussfolgerung ziehen dass wir
dauerhaft in der öffentlichen hand die
verantwortung haben müssen damit wir die
sicherheit für die bürgerinnen und
bürger in diesem land wer leisten können
reprivatisierung ist der falsche weg
meine damen und herren
sie haben in diesem gesetzesentwurf die
kosten des gesetzes nicht beziffert
warum nicht das ist eine frage die muss
spätestens in den beratungen des
gesetzes beantwortet werden oder soll es
wieder so sein wie bei der finanzkrise
und der korea krise die rechnung wird
der bevölkerung nach der krise vorgelegt
das darf nicht sein das können wir nicht
akzeptieren
meine damen und herren die
energieversorger haben in den letzten
jahrzehnten dass das billig in russland
eingekauft und teuer in deutschland
verkauft die bucher gewinne wurden nie
von der bundesregierung abgeschöpft und
in schlechten zeiten soll spekulanten
vom staat das heißt vom steuerzahler
gerettet werden das ist nicht gerecht
das können wir nicht mit nach meine
damen und herren
die in abi
ein käufer dürfen immer noch nach diesem
gesetz traumpreise von den kunden
verlangen wir fordern als linke nicht
nur eine staatliche preiskontrolle
sondern auch eine deckelung der
innerlichen preise damit die menschen
ihr leben noch finanzieren können meine
landtag
vielleicht ein kurzer blick zurück in
die geschichte
in den usa wurde 1980 eine zufalls
gewinn steuer eingeführt und zwar im
zusammenhang mit dem damaligen
arabischen öl embargo da wurden die mehr
gewinne abgeschöpft und wenn das in den
usa möglich ist da frage ich sie warum
soll das in einem land wie unserem nicht
möglich sein meine damen und herren
die menschen in unserem land wissen in
vielen fällen nicht mehr wie sie ihr
leben finanzieren wollen sollen da
brauchen wir wirklich wirksame
gegenmaßnahmen hilfs päckchen reicht
nicht wir brauchen grundlegende
sicherheit wir brauchen grundlegende
kritische infrastrukturen öffentliche
hand das öffentliche macht unser leben
sich rat vielen dank
die bundesrepublik deckte im vergangenen
jahr fast 27 prozent ihres
energiebedarfs mit erdgas und dafür ist
russland das wichtigste herkunftsland
mit 55 prozent
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen lassen sie mich
zu beginn vielleicht noch mal
klarstellen die energiepolitik der
vergangenen regierungen war und ist
breiter gesellschaftlicher konsens und
die unabhängigkeit von fossilen energien
ist nicht dumm sondern klug
als ich am 24 februar aufgewacht bin
habe ich gedacht ich bin im falschen
film denn nur im film sollten kriege
seuchen und katastrophen zu sehen sein
aber der film in dem wir uns befinden
das realität und leider übertrumpft die
realität die phantasie nicht nur
flutkatastrophen hungersnöte oder
pandemien sondern auch mit einem
grausamen angriffskrieg mitten im herzen
europas und die betroffenen können
leider nicht einfach den fernseher
ausschalten und ins bett gehen das heißt
wenn wir uns wünschen dass gewisse dinge
nur im film zu sehen sind müssen wir uns
darauf vorbereiten dass sie irgendwann
auch realität werden können und ein
ziemlich ernstes szenario auf das wir
uns vorbereiten müssen ist dass wir
eines tages ohne russischen gas
auskommen müssen das kann von heute auf
morgen passieren dann wird das gas für
heizung und produktion knapp und die
bundesnetzagentur muss den gasfluss
regulieren
einige hoffen dann vielleicht dass der
präsident der bundesnetzagentur klaus
müller mit einem goldenen schlüssel den
gashahn aufgedreht und das gas fair
verteilt aber
sind wir mal ehrlich so wird es nicht
laufen und deswegen sorgen wir mit
diesem gesetz vor
klaus müller sprach kürzlich davon dass
man in dieser situation nur
entscheidungen treffen kann die
weniger falsch sind als andere und ich
möchte in dieser situation auch nicht
mit ihm tauschen ich will ihm aber mit
diesem gesetz etwas wichtiges mitgeben
an die hand geben eine digitale
plattform denn um das gas zu verteilen
muss man erst einmal wissen wie viel gas
gebraucht wird und wofür
und diese informationen werden künftig
zentral von der bundesnetzagentur
gesammelt und digital verwaltet und das
wird er wird uns in zukunft fundierte
entscheidungen im krisenfall ermöglichen
meine damen und herren
wenn das gas zugeteilt wird muss es aber
immer noch jemand bezahlen dafür gibt es
bisher noch kein drehbuch
denn können die importeure den zu
erwartenden preisanstieg nicht
weiterreichen und gehen deshalb
insolvenz kommt gar kein gas mehr an und
deswegen haben wir in diesem gesetz
festgelegt dass der preisaufschlag
weitergereicht wird und werden kann aber
dafür legen wir ganz enge und
transparente kriterien festlegen klar
ist niemand soll sich an der not anderer
bereichern
sicher ist aber auch in dieser situation
werden die preise steigen um wir müssen
soziale härten abfangen aber das ist
nicht kern dieses gesetzes dieses gesetz
regelt die
sichere energieversorgung und ich
spreche bewusst von energie denn
absehbar soll es auf alle relevanten
energieträger angewandt werden dieses
gesetz sorgt dafür dass auch in der
akuten krisensituation alle haushalte in
deutschland weiterhin im warmen einen
film schauen können und es hilft uns uns
vor politischer erpressung zu schützen
und damit stärkt unsere position für die
derzeit größte herausforderung europas
anderen zu helfen aus ihrem horrorfilm
aufzuwachen der am 24 februar über sie
hereingebrochen ist vielen dank
markus huber war das hier noch in der
debatte in der ersten beratung des
gesetzentwurfes zur änderung des energie
sicherungs gesetzes das die ampel
fraktionen vorgelegt haben und andreas
lenz spricht jetzt für die
unionsfraktion
und herren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen der völkerrechtswidrige
angriffskrieg putins auf die ukraine hat
zu einer angespannten situation im
energiemarkt geführt die preise sind
hoch die unsicherheit ist groß die
risiken sind nach wie vor groß und auf
jeden fall vorhanden das wissen wir alle
und gerade jetzt ist der blick auf die
versorgungssicherheit wichtig die
russischen gasmenge müssen so schnell
wie möglich durch andere potenziale
substituiert werden aber auch die
kritische infrastruktur in deutschland
muss aufrecht erhalten bleiben sollte es
eine gefährdung oder störungen der
energieversorgung geben müssen
handlungsmöglichkeiten zur
krisenbewältigung und auch zur
prävention geschaffen werden und das ist
mit diesem geschäft gesetzentwurf
intendiert und ich möchte ausdrücklich
betonen dass ihr das vorgehen vom
grundsatz her aus staatspolitischer
verantwortung heraus unterstützen bei
gazprom germania war es nur zufällig
durch das außenwirtschaftsgesetz möglich
das unternehmen unter treuhandschaft zu
stehen die rechtsgrundlage für solche
fälle muss also breiter aufgestellt sein
auch dazu soll die reform entsprechend
dienen treuhand modelle werden
ermöglicht wenn unternehmen ihren
aufgaben nicht mehr hinreichend
nachkommen können oder wollen und
dadurch eine beeinträchtigung der
versorgungssicherheit tut und als ultima
ratio es wurde schon gesagt wirklich nur
im äußersten fall dann wenn keine
milderen mittel vorhanden sind muss es
auch möglich sein staatliche
beteiligungen oder auch enteignungen zu
ermöglichen ich möchte aber an dieser
stelle sagen hier muss das gesetz noch
konkreter werden und die dann eventuell
verstaatlichten unternehmen müssen
natürlich auch wieder sukzessive
privatisiert werden in zukunft muss eine
stille von ga speicheranlagen angezeigt
und von der bundesnetzagentur genehmigt
werden das ist im sinne der
versorgungssicherheit zu begrüßen die
bundesregierung soll zur umsetzung der
krisenmaßnahmen digitale plattformen
errichten können ein besserer überblick
über die frage wo sich der
energieeinsatz im krisenfall schnell
reduzieren lässt ist natürlich notwendig
und sinnvoll und da drängen wir auch
gerne darauf dass die fertigstellung
dieser plattform schon vor dem zehnten
möglich sein könnte also hier auch
unterstützung aber auch ihm der wille
und auch der auftrag da etwas schneller
zu sein wenn es um die preisfindung geht
dann sieht auch hier das gesetz etwaige
eingriffe vor der paragraph 27 wir sind
daher der meinung dass dieser paragraf
noch zu prüfen ist diese eingriffe
könnten im schlechtesten fall sogar
kontraproduktiv hinsichtlich der
versorgungssicherheit seien ebenso gibt
es noch unklarheiten weigern
zuständigkeiten zwischen den ländern und
der bundesnetzagentur und insgesamt
brauchen wir noch deutlich mehr
transparenz deutlich mehr informationen
und auch deutlich mehr einbeziehung vor
allem was das parlament aber auch
natürlich in dem kontext die opposition
begriff wir wollen auch wissen ob es
schon konkrete fälle gibt wo die
regelungen zum einsatz kommen könnten
und auch übrigens eine einbeziehung der
länder ist bei einem gesetz mit so
weitreichenden auswirkungen wichtig und
notwendig und auch darauf werden wir
drängen wenn wir irgendwann verfahren
entgegen kommen dann müssen sie das auch
entsprechend mit beteiligung aber auch
mit anderer wertschätzung entsprechend
honorieren in dem sinne sollen wir uns
auf die beratungen die wir konstruktiv
begleiten herzlichen dank
um der kollege bank berg der spd
fraktion ist der letzte redner in der
debatte
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen kollegen liebe bürgerinnen
bürger wir hören ja schon wieder immer
die gleiche leier von der afd von
atomkraft immer wieder immer wieder
unser problem ist die wärme sie haben
offensichtlich nicht zugehört und da
helfen auch alle möglichen
stromlieferungen nichts wenn wir keine
electro cancer haben um die werbe
herzustellen da arbeiten wir dran wir
bauen das aus
aber noch brauchen wir gar am besten co2
neutral auch das bauen wir gerade aus
aber jetzt noch importieren wir gas zu
einem großen teil von dem regime was
diesen krieg zu verantworten hat und
dass energiepolitik gezielt als waffe
einsetzt das zeigt nicht zuletzt
russlands importstopp nach polen
bulgarien aber ein teil der lieferungen
nach polen er setzt deutschland bereits
und griechenland hat bulgarien hilfe
zugesichert meine damen und herren das
ist gelebte solidarität in europa mit
diesen schweren wochen und monaten
und auch um diese solidarität zu sichern
schützen wir die energieversorgung in
deutschland und europa mit dem update
des energie sicherungs gesetzes bringen
wir den instrumentenkasten unseres
staates auf die höhe der zeit als
demokratie sind wir im gegensatz zu
einem autokratischen regime aber an
verfassungsrechtliche schranken gebunden
verträge müssen gelten und gewalt darf
niemals ein mittel politische
wirtschaftliche oder gesellschaftliche
auseinandersetzung sein als demokratie
können wir unseren staat aber ein gut
bestimmten werkzeugkasten an die hand
geben um sich zu wehren und seine
bürgerinnen und bürger zu schützen ein
wehrhafter start ist ein starker staat
meine damen und herren und dafür steht
die ampel koalition
mit dem gesetz mit dem gesetz was wir
heute auf den weg bringen schaffen wir
rechtssicherheit und berechenbarkeit für
die akteure am markt 4 kernbotschaften
möchte ich hervorheben erst wir sorgen
vor sollte eine gefährdung die der
energieversorgung bestehen erhalten bund
und länder weitgehende
handlungsmöglichkeiten unter anderem zur
einsparung von gas und öl das ist der
schraubendreher mit dem wir
feinjustieren können 2 wir haben den
besonderen wir wollen den markt ja nicht
abwürgen da wo der markt die
energieversorgung regeln kann dann soll
er das ruhig tun das ist in ordnung da
aber wo das nicht funktioniert kann der
staat dann eingreifen durch das verbot
benötigte gasspeicher stillzulegen das
ist im werkzeugkasten quasi die klemme
die wir brauchen um kapazität am markt
zu halten und wenn es nötig ist legen
wir auf den schraubstock an durch eine
treuhänderische verwaltung von
energieunternehmen durch den staat und
als absolute ultima ratio müssen wir
auch zur brechstange der enteignung
greifen können und zwar nicht nur damit
es im linken ohr klingelt sondern nur
dann wenn die sicherung der
energieversorgung nicht anders
gewährleistet werden kann
für uns ist klar ein von russland
angezettelte energie krieg darf nicht zu
energie not führen meine damen und
herren drittens vier millionen
arbeitsplätze hängen direkt oder
indirekt allein an der nutzung von
erdgas das energie sicherungs gesetz ist
damit auch ein arbeits sicherungs gesetz
es gibt unserer starken volkswirtschaft
damit die nötige ausdauer in der
auseinandersetzung mit putins regime und
viertens wir sind solidarisch mit
unseren europäischen nachbarn die
instrumente dieses gesetzes muss
deutschland auch dann anwenden können
wenn ein mitgliedsstaat der eu
energieprobleme kommt kommen sie bitte
zum schluss auch dafür schaffen wir die
möglichen nötigen rechtlichen
voraussetzungen denn eins muss klar sein
gerade in diesen schlimmen tagen muss
energiepolitik auch immer ein zeichen
europäischer solidarität sein meine
damen und herren vielen dank
die ampel koalition möchte die möglichen
maßnahmen erweitern die regierung und
behörden auf paragrafen können wenn es
zur gefährdung der versorgung von
zb energie geht und deswegen soll das
energie sicherungs gesetz geändert
werden
dazu haben wir eben die erste beratung
gehört und der gesetzentwurf der
fraktionen von spd bündnis 90/die grünen
und fdp wird jetzt die entsprechenden
ausschüsse überwiesen dort weiter
diskutiert da gab es ja auch schon
einige diskussionspunkte die
angesprochen wurden und kommt daniel
wieder in den plenarsaal zur weiteren
beratung